giornata di blog mas e ringo cosa stai
facendo
sto cucinando stai cercando di
avvelenarci nell'aria se sia inter 2 di
calzolai
oddio oddio assumere 100 critica poi
quando le mangerai mi dirai enrico aimi
ragione sentono l'odore del bar
questo è l'odore giusto questa ragione
della befana
marco mi scappano nel frattempo ma è
perché mi ha dato questo per mangiare
devo prenderla così così prendi buona
eccellente cracco tra cui i fatti sta
d'altra parte è un'esperienza sensoriale
sui un pessimo certi queste gambe liceo
vincenti il fumo
no questa non mangiare così tanti mostri
tutto esatto ma ci poteva strada nel
senso che non ci faceva maniera spalto
fondata dal mio cv vuoi che muore
chiamati i pompieri
le due quello se neppure andato oggi a
te non toccate la mia ricetta
fidatevi scrivetelo sulla mia tomba si
fidò che gli omicidi ma cambia ma una
certa attore occorre dettato sulla
barella non può carbonizzate non leggono
nemmeno male vero
aiutato dal dolore banda rotti per
mangiare ci sediamo no bisogna mangiarli
in piedi sui roghi ardenti che riappare
loro quindi devi salire sulle cotolette
reati le bollette
così questo più o meno è il microfono
della carta da calcola che l arrivo in
realtà ancora di capirlo che il
microfono
questo qui sopra e microfoni si sente
niente
strano perché tu solitamente con la
macchina ci spazi pavimenti mar trovo in
funzione in bocca si chiama cimitero
presente quando benin possa scendere
almeno non sono brindò no
tutti saremo noi pare che hanno pagato a
dire queste cose se ne pacini pubblico
l'olio ma poi vuoi mettere da morto non
mangi nemmeno a qualcuno la vuole
non ho creato già fumato io mi sono dato
al brodo perché avevo l'asfalto in bocca
non apprezzate della cucina
d'avanguardia questo il fatto
avanguardia air a con la secca è la
cucina da una guardia nel senso che devi
stare in guardia
ma qualcuno ha un bicchiere d'olio guido
il modello di oggi ti sei alcuni cui
poter pensare assoluto a casa di mio
fratello per farmi avvelenare la realtà
è un'altra il vero protagonista di
questa puntata del blog masche lui ho
comprato i vestitini per culto che gli
volevo far provare divertenti e ridicoli
ora io non amo gli animali vestiti
perché gli piacciono gli animali in
quanto animali o per una volta ci si può
divertire un pochino con il proprio
delizioso cagnolino inoltre mi sono
arrivati due regali sempre per gould che
volevo fargli indossare per i quali ho
aspettato un pochino in blog per
l'inserire all'interno di questo video è
avere più outfit da testare a sé dire il
vero e proprio grazie a questi due
regalini che mi è venuta l'idea culto
sei pronto per essere una star
un giallo la coscia dei mini vedermi
sviluppato praticamente te lo sei rubato
ti salverà il mercato è arrivato e ha
curato da disney hanno mandato un
maglione per l'ipo carino e ridosso
subito il mio un patch i miti di
guglielmo fiesolana di tempo sarebbe
stato un bello spettacolo dopo il tempo
è passato da molti anni ca valente si
ragazzi vorrei ricordare a tutti quanti
che è tutto dicembre cioè il 50 per
cento di sconto sulle magliette di b e
pay back d e k della spedizione cure
gratis
detto ciò scusate non stiamo parlando di
me luigi sembra gigante un'ottima
texture infatti sta il awards oddio ma
questi qui sono primo plastificate
bellissimo mi devi toccare i primi sei
pazzo compimento di adesso culto
mettiamo il tuo bellissimo maglione
vieni qui la spazzatura
mi sa che è giusto
facciamogli fare una sfilata targhetti
di fuori
siete quindi si sta la rivolta nello
studio questo è il primo out prima di
samp ott il latino uneasy cioè touring
spezia che se qui togliamolo bravi ma
questo è un altro pacco che in ed oli
per lolli petta esatto elisabetta
fanfani che carissimo culto ci pensiamo
noi a ripararsi dal freddo con il nostro
maglioncino modello fiorella tutti i
modelli di lolli pet sono realizzati con
tessuti di alta moda alta moda
[Musica]
personalizzabili e tailor made non
vediamo l'ora di vederti con il tuo
nuovo luca che carini su internet per
diventare l'arma vediamo questo pure
dalla juve per fermo
io non capisco perché pensa quindi cosa
sia vivente chiudi gli occhi 20 quad
entro la faccia tu devi passare qua
dentro
ok burdo perfetto ragazza è fantastico
al mazza
ok sfilata e fantasma e stefan analogico
abbiamo di croccantini vieni qui qui qui
qui qui e vieni qui qui qui qui qui qui
noi giriamo in cui seduto bravissimo più
bravo io credo che le persone debbano
dai punti quindi ero in silenzio faccio
vedere il modello è sempre lui
meraviglioso bravissimo togliamo questo
qua no da poco una tale momento della
verità i maglioni tutto a posto arriverà
già aspettassi ha modellato la snow al
secondo
abbiamo fatto provare due maglioni
quello di disney ed il o libertà guido
che è stato tranquillo perché lui aveva
abituato d'inverno ammettere che ne so
il maglioncino quando esce fuori che fa
freddissimo o impermeabile quando piove
appena però abbiamo tirato fuori babbo
natale è il consiglio ma tu non hai
capito
voi non potete capire che cosa non
voleva fare a lui mai è il questore
richiamo come bolzano forzare un cane
permettere una roba che fa ridere noi e
non far divertire il cane anche no
grazie e quindi abbiamo pensato a bestie
per il video è molto meglio far passare
il messaggio del può essere divertente
se i tuoi animali sono sereni se non lo
sono perché vogliono distruggere il
babbo natale evitiamo evitiamo di fare
questa roba più di strumentalizzare
mercificare comunque delle vite per
quanto animali e 7 delle vite questo qui
è il modello babbo natale e bala questo
è un tuffo al cuore giallo mamma il
moderno dolce rehn del natale questo lo
accetterebbe per me non lo accetterebbe
con veramente margine cooper è un dato
ben giro su questa è decisamente piccolo
pirata non c'era ragazzi questa è una
roba ondata con la raffaella roba
pazzesca e infine il mio preferito buldo
sposa non sarebbe durato neanche evita
di scartarlo doveva fare un esperimento
con questo dai ci provano a mettere dove
c'è il guinzaglio variety diamo a
riprendere questo adesso l'opposizione o
qui dove ci avevo il taglio nel modo che
più naturale capito riconosce comunque
sia qualcosa di amico andiamo a provare
venite con me
andiamo da fermo qui fermo è bravo
e dov'è no per niente molto dai basta
bravo lasciamo perdere
esperimento riuscito a gianluigi dog
whisperer ragazzi gianmarco per il verde
come il tempo lo vedi usato no il tempo
lo smog il piaceri possono rovinare una
canzone enrico da piccolo è un po quale
c'è l'effetto che enrico se ne mangia di
57 questo il grido che piace a noi
sereno tra le braccia del suo mano
preferito che questo qui è il ricco di
tensione noi sereno con indirizzo
padrone allora ragazzi guglielmo è
uscito di casa si è scordato la camera
perciò deciso di rovinargli questo blog
a cominciare quindi da questo questo
eccesso che ad hoc e lo diciamo per
espletare tutti i miei bisogni questo è
un altro processo
qui abbiamo un bellissimo e dei piccoli
scherzetti natalizi
[Risate]
ora lanciamo un dado chi perde mangia un
croccantino per cani madonna io marco lo
tanto peggio di così non può andare
giochi o no accordo mira io no sì ma le
serp at t ha mandato chi perde mangio
entro il cantino per cani quarantina di
sì ma doveva generi tanti
così le probabilità di gioco non abbiamo
scelto innanzitutto un da dino e questo
è il premio del perdente
un gioco che devi solamente tirare un
dato stiamo facendo sul gioco che
giocare pure tu
praticamente tv il dato se fai il numero
più basso mangi un croccantino di culto
però mi pare che al cane l'olympic si
vola roba degli uomini viene pure caffè
e ammazzacaffè senese finale
dell'olimpico rubate di noi esseri umani
quindi è giusto che anche tu provi
assaggi il croccantino il cane ragazzi
reggiani linee ecco un altro giocatore
321 ex basso è mangiare con uno bambini
a dopo il pari è già salvo 56.81
attenzione 6 non s'è visto niente devi
di tirare silani croccantina vinto il
pubblico non può essere soddisfatto cava
infatti nuove gara ha capito rimarrei di
gioco lo abbiamo fatto
quanti ce ne sono ancora
44 buon numero 5 si si si hai massimo
dove punto grazie
[Musica]
proprio regalato cinque hai vinto di
nuovo e robusta 3 a 1 al 3 reti e via
ieri e mi sto per levare dal popolo 1
visto prelevare sì e io voglio parlando
[Applauso]
di sicuro non mangerò ma chi è questo il
numero basso salvati ecologiche regala
sei mesi ma tanto peggio di così non può
andare
e questo per esso sia non sappiate
questo è bello no lo show più belle da
mamme franci e crunchy a mia bocca
mo ti dico che cosa ne pensi o fai una
decina le sale
tutto sommato devo dire che si può fare
né assaggio un altro posso dire che c'è
un diverso di me una bmv ipad e conte
calo dieci anni che soffrono quanti
reich 50 a 50 light a 50.000 like faremo
mangiare a guglielmo a sua insaputa
perché angela senza infatti faremo
mangiare a guglielmo una bella scagliata
di mangime quello lì per gatti per
carico e l'umido delle scatolette
avete presente orribili va bè quello lì
allora altri modi per rovinare questo
blog mas possono essere ad esempio
parlare di calcio
l'olio il calcio è una diventa anche
sognato ma ragazzo sta passando il turno
ne vogliamo parlare scrivete tutti i
sotto nei commenti forzata
per cui pietro è il blog ci pensiamo noi
tranquillo tranquillo corso è in ottime
mani
massimo la carica di 101 da me senti
adesso ci siamo
ci siamo spostati
dobbiamo rovinare il blog ma fa cadere
quindi video mostra sul vostro canale
mese ma mi hanno sversato
se state ancora lontana ma c'è una
boscaiole per margherite sei un porco
capire per chi non lo sapesse di enrico
tifiamo juve e quindi perfetto fatto il
boom dei buffi come detto non ti
preoccupare non è infatti non militare
ma non insista a tema dimetto di foglie
realistico sofferte ciò 5 5 però su cosa
gli angoli poi spicco mese in mese del
none grazie a conti fatti ma sapendo
molto preparata ma per me fermo madrina
alla fame si no
adesso facciamo l'agguato al pizzettaro
[Risate]
ma se una dieta varia e come sei come la
vision 6 sbaglia e quella devi scappare
esatto primo tempo 0 0 non troppe
emozioni in parte un palo per leverkusen
a coppie di due tappe david wain cosa
del pane arnaldo un po a ritardo e
l'altra mezza occasione insomma partita
normale
dobbiamo augurarci un gol per cr7 è
stata chiusa questa linea di passaggio
a porta vuota mi piace così ecco il tuo
a 0 partita chiusa
e forse è qua che possiamo chiudere
l'appuntamento della champions league
ormai sei padrone dovrebbe finire lo
zero ci vediamo al prossimo appuntamento
ragazzi mi hai fatta ragazzi che cosa
hai fatto
posso dirti una cosa questo è il blog
più bello se tu abbia mai fatto ragazzi
non voglio sapere cosa fatta di dati io
fidati fidatevi si vedono sulla mia
tomba si fidò chiedo scusa sulla fiducia
e mi sono dimenticato a casa ha
convenuto tra come convenuto si fatemi
sapere scrivendo scusato se vi ha fatto
schifo
oppure ne voglio ancora se vi è piaciuto
ne vedrai molti di questi possono ri
averla è una cosa intanto ringrazia
ringrazia perché che abbiamo portato il
blog a casa io temo che l'abbia portato
nella latrina tu il blog però grazie
ragazzi perché sennò è comunque un
contenuto è comunque un contenuto
allora sulla fiducia vi chiedo anche
scusa i nostri protagonisti andrà a
questo punto che danno un appuntamento a
domani
era meglio adova alla prostata